you might already be planning to go
trick-or-treating or binging the new
season of stranger things this Halloween
but there will also be a few freaky
horror flicks worth checking out around
All Hallows Eve from the return of a few
major franchises to creative genre
Busters and intriguing indie scare fest
here are all the new horror films that
will blow you away this Halloween cult
of Chucky you just can't keep a
murderous doll down dating back to
Chucky's debut in 1988 the childsplay
franchise has spanned six films all with
a nightmare haunting toys stalking and
murdering without abandon cult of Chucky
picks up as a sequel to 2013's curse of
chucky with a young woman in a mental
institution being gifted a doll that
turns out to be the murderous plaything
the film will bring back Alex Vinson
Chucky's original victim as well as
Chucky's wife Tiffany and Nika peers
from curse of chucky and of course the
doll that started it all count on this
one to haunt your childhood all over
again when it hits theaters on October
3rd
we're friends to the end better watch
out this Christmas set slasher pick has
already proven to be a hit on the
festival circuit the film might be a bit
formulaic as it features a routine night
of babysitting that goes horribly wrong
but critics have been especially
impressed with this holiday themed tale
of a young woman fighting off intruders
while protecting her preteen charge so
we can probably expect better watch out
to give Santa's naughty list a whole new
meaning after this one drops on October
6th happy death day what happens when
you mash up Groundhog Day with a horror
flick happy death day aims to find out
by featuring a young woman who basically
has to relive her birthday over and over
again to find out who's murdering her
[Music]
it's a teenage last year with a clever
twist and it could be just the thing to
lure horror fans to the theater again
and again when it arrives in October
13th
Leatherface the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
franchise has been going strong for five
decades so it shouldn't be too much of a
surprise that another installment of the
og slasher classic is coming this
Halloween season
this time it's Leatherface which will
focus in on the early days of The
Namesake killer years before the events
depicted in the original chain saw the
film aims to build an origin story about
the title character revealing the future
murderer was once a troubled youth
involved in the mysterious death of the
local sheriff's daughter he spends 10
years in
hospital before his gaping and then the
manhunt begins with the deranged
revenge-seeking sheriff out for leather
faces hide prepare for jump scares in
gore galore when this pic hits theaters
on October 20th the snow man talk about
a cult case and this crime thriller an
investigator is reminded of a very old
murder case when he finds a victim scarf
tighter on the neck of a snowman and
begins thawing out other unsolved
murders that might be related but by
getting too snowed into the case our
hero might find that icy glare trainin
himself and his loved ones sooner than
later get ready to experience all the
chills when the Snowman hits theatres
October 20th jigsaw the 7th installment
of the Saw series was supposed to be its
last but with so many games yet to be
played the filmmakers on jigsaw turned
on their tape recorder for another round
this time the film will follow a new
mysterious killer who gathers a group of
victims to torture but while the title
character of jigsaw has been dead for
years investigators start to notice some
striking similarities between his
original work and his new protegees the
truth will set you free these supposed
copycat killings will serve as a
reminder of the best and worst of the
prior installments and introduce some
new Horrors with a trap happy fan base
so get ready to make your choice on
October 27 no it's not creepy at all
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]